talk a little bit about that like the
communication methods that you use uh
would be more akin to uh somebody like
myself uh or an investor or an
entrepreneur on the internet in terms of
kind of building in public and openly
engaging with people most politicians
frankly seem to be doing the exact
opposite they want as little interaction
as possible they don't want to kind of
take questions uh from the public let
alone from uh reporters etc so why take
this path that others may deem a little
counter-intuitive for somebody in your
position
i'll be honest with you you know
initially i was sort of the conventional
i mean i think i did a little bit
differently and a little bit more
exciting and a little bit more um
cutting edge because i'm younger but i
think i was generally speaking within
the range of what somebody would
consider typical right we would post you
know events and things like that
after the how can i help tweet when i
realized that we were onto something and
what i realized that there were sub
communities in twitter that were
extremely positive that wanted to build
uh that wanted uh you know to support
people that felt the way that they felt
uh i i sort of got i sort of fell in
love with with the idea of being able to
communicate and hyper communicate with a
group of people that were like me right
that that were young that that were
excited about the future of our country
that wanted to innovate that realized
that that the key to our uh to our
success was to be the most innovative
country and the most innovative city on
the planet and so it it you know
successfully gets success so the more
positivity that i encountered
uh the more i went all in and i think uh
you know the same thing happened with
bitcoin you know when i started on some
of these bitcoin initiatives i realized
that there was a huge um a community of
bitcoin followers and enthusiasts that
were excited about some of the
initiatives that we were doing and i
remember you know we had uh
you know we announced the the resolution
that we put out that allowed for our
employees to get paid in bitcoin allows
for fees and taxes to get paid in
bitcoin and talks about us holding it on
our balance sheet i think we put it out
at like on thursday night you know
random hour wasn't done at a
particularly strategic time and we got
millions and millions of views of that
video because people were so excited
about you know government innovating and
and and mainstreaming a technology that
so many people um were involved in and
that was kind of probably more under the
radar than people thought
when you think about bitcoin uh i you
know had a conversation with you i think
back in uh probably either november or
december of last year uh and then again
uh in the beginning of uh this year and
one of the things that really struck me
was uh most folks would hear bitcoin or
some of these technologies and say oh
that's you know that's cute uh but
instead one of the questions you said to
me was just like hey you know what
should we be doing here and so walk us
through kind of your journey uh with
bitcoin i believe that you've said
publicly that you own some um but just
kind of how have you uh you know kind of
educated yourself and then what are your
thoughts today i was talking to my team
earlier today they call it my laser eye
journey
you know and so my my laser eye journey
sort of began a while ago actually
probably earlier than people think i was
part of
something called the blockchain
foundation and i was also asked by the
cfo of florida to be part of the
blockchain task force so that was the
state's a vehicle looking at this
technology before
you know uh it became as popular as it
is right now i think you know for me
i i love the mathematics of it i loved
the way that it that the way that it was
created um you know nobody wanting to
necessarily take credit for it but
building something that was going to be
driven by a decentralized network of
people
transparent
and it wasn't necessarily somebody
coming out and say i'm the guy that you
know created this i also thought that
the the the disconnection or dislocation
from fiat was revolutionary and very
much appealed to because i see
you know governments continue
continually domestically and foreign uh
foreign probably worse uh in terms of
the currency manipulation corruption
that we see in governments and things of
that nature and this solves for that and
so there you know bitcoin solves for
that and so for me
um i i
saw the runway and i'll tell you there's
so many people that told me you know
stop
don't do it uh you know bitcoin is x or
y or z or whatever whatever you know
fill in the blank criticism right and
and from my perspective i i just saw
opportunity you know what i mean like i
think you and i talked about this or you
had put out a challenge at one point to
see you know
you know who could put satoshi's white
paper on their website fastest right and
i think maybe estonia beat us uh
so we were the first government in north
america in in the world other than
estonia uh to put satoshi's white paper
and i just thought you know that's that
is a low-hanging fruit you know putting
putting a white paper of an innovator uh
creating something that's revolutionary
what's what's what's the downside but i
think in government people are always
afraid they're afraid to innovate
they're afraid to be criticized right
because everybody's afraid of that and
then i said you know and then you know i
have friends that are in the community
and they said hey what's your encore
like what's next you know so obviously
you know the laser eyes thing was a was
a cool moment and and and certainly uh
you know this this resolution of of
going a step beyond making it more
substantive right and saying like hey
you know now i want my employees to be
able to get paid you know there was a
very famous nfl player who wanted his
contract paid in bitcoin and i think by
the time you know he went from being
like a regular average nfl player to
being like the third highest offensive
lineman uh you know and i thought you
know it it'd be cool to give my
employees that opportunity you know and
then and and so we started working on
stuff like that and that's how how my
integration into bitcoin uh you know has
has continued obviously i see what's
happening in china and i think it's an
enormous geopolitical strategic
opportunity for the united states i've
been involved with a variety of uh
bitcoin miners uh particularly in the
united states i've talked to power
companies in the united states there was
an article today in the washington post
i'm sorry i'm sorry the new york
in the uh wall street journal my
apologies sorry wall street journal uh
talking about my interactions with uh
the power company here which is a
nuclear power company and miners to try
to get clean energy mining which i think
the esg issue has been completely
manipulated uh and and and has been
completely unfairly characterized the
bitcoin community as one that doesn't
care about esg and i find that to be
exactly the opposite i think uh all the
bitcoin miners that i've met and i've
seen facilities that are incredible will
blow your mind they're doing it with in
completely carbon neutral um there is no
uh you know no dirty emissions so i
think you know part of the reason why
there was that reputation was because a
lot of the money was happening in china
i think the fact that china decided to
shut it down and continues to be
antagonistic to bitcoin is a massive
opportunity for this country i think
it's a massive opportunity not just for
urban america but for middle america uh
and i think what we have to be careful
with is to make sure that none of our
laws
antagonize this
burgeoning innovation and what i've done
at the state level i've helped introduce
a state legislative
law
that was frankly copying wyoming uh we
wanted to be the most crypto friendly
state in the nation uh we've obviously
passed some of these laws at the city
and we're now going on rfp in october to
select the vendor to hopefully be able
to you know effectuate some of these
ideas that we had so we're continuing to
move the ball forward and it's just very
exciting hey guys bang bang thanks so
much for watching the best business show
today and don't forget to check out our
partner sofi they make all this possible
they're a super app that lets you save
spend borrow earn and invest all from
one single platform and if you go there
today and you sign up for a sofi invest
account you can get between five dollars
and a thousand bucks for free from sofa
not everyone's obviously gonna get a
thousand dollars but everyone gets
something don't say that i never did
anything for you go check them out at
sofi.compomp
download the app and go ahead and open
an account sofi.com pomp and make sure
you come back and watch more of the best
business show we're gonna build the
biggest business show in the world and
we need your help
[Music]